- [Gary] When you
always think that
this thing is
gonna be the thing.
I always thought like this
appearance on Jimmy Fallon is
gonna be the thing. Right?
Or this podcast with
Rogan is gonna be the thing.
Or this person following me on
social media is
gonna be the thing.
None of it's the thing.
It's just another block.
- [Alex] Another stepping stone.
- Another stepping stool.
And the quicker you think about
bricks instead of a pre-fabed
building, the quicker you win.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
When do we go on the
offense on the new class?
- [AJ] Immediately.
- The guys in the
middle of the
second, third round?
- [AJ] After we sign this guy
that we're signing next week.
- Yeah.
- (censored) is
dropping me in his new album.
- [AJ] Nice. That's cool.
- And wants me to come
in studio and be on it.
I mean he's big, big, big, big.
- [AJ] Yeah.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, that's good.
- [AJ] It's all
Biz Dev Sunday stuff.
It's all stuff that Justin's
pulling out of the woodwork.
- Quick Biz Dev Sunday, I'm
telling you right now if you're
a startup brand, this a
commercial inside of DailyVee.
If you're a startup brand and
you really want to get into the
sports game, you
should hit us up.
Put the email down here, Tyler.
Biz Dev Sunday, not for product.
We're looking for
dollars, you know,
5, 10, 15, $100,000 deals for
our athletes but what we'll be
able to do above and beyond the
exposure of having NFL rookie
that you can build with
is a relationship with me,
us, and the things
we'll do in this campaign.
So we did a bunch of brands
from the first Biz Dev Sunday.
They are super
pumped, we are happy.
- [AJ] Good progress, yep.
- And we're gonna
have a big class next year.
We have a lot going on.
This is exactly the time to
hit up Biz Dev Sunday if...
I think certain categories
are already done, right?
Like, we can't do--
- Yeah, it's player by player.
- [Gary] Got it, okay.
- [AJ] Yeah.
- You'll regret it.
(chuckles) That's incredible.
("Pure Maiz" by Ethinikids)
Great. This is about
to get really pissed.
- [Claude] Yeah, cool.
- For me, it feels way
more (censored) with us.
- Keep that.
But I have a funny feeling the
right thing to do is to have
people check
their egos at the door.
- Yeah.
- I just think we
have to break our reality.
And it's time
for me to break it.
It's my job.
- [Alex] Good
to finally meet ya.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure, man.
Real pleasure.
- You as well.
- Alex, Gary.
- Alex. Austin?
- Austin, yeah.
- Real pleasure.
You know, I think that getting
into a market is actually
stunningly easy so I actually
genuinely believe you take the
advice I'm about to
give you it will work.
I'm surprised how
many people overthink it.
I think you need to map every
single buying decision maker in
America and I think
you need to email them,
hit them up on social media and
then surprise and delight them.
- [Alex] I like that.
- Like it's
literally that basic.
You actually
know the 5,000 stores,
distribution centers
you want to be in.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Right, in theory you know?
- You want to be in
Urban Outfitters, I don't know.
You want to be in
this little SoHo shop?
I don't know. That's your
business, I don't know it.
But if I had a wine
I sure know which stores, right?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- So great, you decide
there's 41 boutiques in SoHo
you want to be part of.
You guys sit on fucking
Google, find the person's name,
send them a t-shirt
and a note in the mail.
They get millions of that.
They throw in the garbage
the same way I do. Right?
You email them.
You follow them on
Twitter and Instagram.
You talk to them on
You tag them in some of your
photos on Instagram so it shows
up in their notifications.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- You one-on-one virtually sell
the 1537 people
that make the decision
if this t-shirt goes on a rack.
As you know, in
the last 100 days,
last four months, it's really
starting to pop for me, right?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- And it was like, yo,
how come this is happening?
I'm like 20 fucking
years of fucking hustle, dick.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- That's why it's happening.
- [Alex] Hard work.
- You know what I mean?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- You never know when
it's gonna be that moment.
So look, this is smart.
You got here, this is
fucking free great exposure.
There's cool people that watch.
Great. Good shit could happen.
But you always think this
thing is gonna be the thing.
I always thought like this
appearance on Jimmy Fallon is
gonna be the thing. Right?
Or this podcast with
Rogan is gonna be the thing.
Or this person following
me on social media is
gonna be the thing.
None of it's the thing.
It's just another block.
- [Alex] Another stepping stone.
- Another stepping stool.
And the quicker you think about
bricks instead of a pre-fabed
building, the quicker you win.
I'm being dead serious, man.
- [Alex] I've got the hustle,--
- You've got to know that
missing 11 times and hitting the
one time of the 12 times that
you spent 12 hours
on is ROI positive.
That's what these
fuckers don't get.
- [Alex] Saying, you know,
get at the buyers.
Get at the buyers.
Or is it go on the ground
and hustle store to store.
- Buyers.
- [Alex] Buyers.
- You can't go on the ground.
What are you gonna buy
four-fucking-thousand dollar
Australian
flight ticket and trek,
you don't have that.
You're gonna build
an empire from your bed.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Ready?
I own your business, Australia.
Spend two days with my team.
If the video, Austin.
Austin, no, today
you're not videoing,
today you're fucking on Google.
Google top fucking
clothing stores in Australia.
Rad clothing
stores in Australia.
Go to Instagram and
hashtag Australian clothing,
Australian store
like fucking work.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- On spec, get a list.
Okay, here are the 39
shops we want to be a part of
on the east coast.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Okay, now we
go to their website.
Scroll down, contact,
about me, about me,
Carl Tintinton
started this because his dad
loved the eat coast.
Google Carl Tintinton.
Carl loves
Australian rules football.
Like fucking work.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Then email and say, yo, Carl.
Sorry your team lost last night.
You know?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- Duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
Then you DM him, then you
leave a comment on one of his
Instagram photos.
So you email him,
email his website,
leave a comment on a
post he made on Instagram and
@ him on Twitter.
You guys following?
The work. Got it?
So that's what you do.
Three of those 39
people say yo, send me a shirt.
One of those three you send a
shirt to puts it in their store,
one really smoke show
model walks in there,
wears it, and away you go.
- [Alex] Done, yeah.
- 'Sup man?
- Well, I think it starts with
you doing the right behavior.
So the reason I'm always
confident is I know I'm doing
the right behavior.
So everybody here can
blame me or this and that.
But I'm very comfortable that
I've created the right behavior
and that over time, whether they
believe in me now or over the
long term, that
I'll win that game.
So I think it starts with you.
So for example, I think
it's less about because you're
emotionally intelligent and
you like that space that you're
gonna coach them up or
down or left and right.
I think it's you showing your
lack of insecurity and building
confidence with
everybody up, down,
left and right around you.
Such a pleasure.
- [Erin] Nice to meet you.
- How are you?
- Doing great.
- I like your t-shirt.
- [Erin] Thank you.
What I really appreciated about
the meeting and what sort of
surprised me is that
we know Gary to be
the type to have very
large opinion about
things and talk a lot.
What I really like about Gary
is that he's very different from
when he speaks to large crowds,
when he's in a one-on-one with
you he wants to hear
what you have to say.
And so, I could tell he was
being very mindful about letting
there be quiet space for me
to speak my mind and ask him
whatever I want.
- [Gary] Tell me about yourself.
How long you been here?
- Eight months.
- [Gary] And?
- From Atlanta,
used to work with Lee.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Been doing search.
Before that, I did PR.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Been in the world for like
five, six years. Lovin' it.
I'm liking it. I'm a huge nerd.
So PR is fun but the second
I started doing search I was
like (sighs), this feels great.
I have data.
I know what my
efforts are doing now so...
Next question.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- What's on your mind?
- [Gary] Right this second
or overall?
- Interpret that as you like it.
- [Gary] Just executing
on the gratitude I have that
I have all this in me. You know?
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] That's
what's on my mind.
- Executing gratitude.
- [Gary] Executing on the
gratitude I have for the things
I was gifted with
'cause I know I'm different.
- I would agree with that.
- [Gary] You know?
It's the truth.
That's the most macro
answer to your question.
Some people are born all-time
great athletes and singers.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] I just think I can
re-invent the way
businesses are built. Big ones.
And I want to do that.
Okay.
- [Tyler] So Thursday...
- That's good, that's good.
("The Creation of
Earth" by Vvitch)
- [Gary] Mr. Falk,
I'm sorry I'm late.
Good to see you.
- Love this place.
Thank you, come on.
- College, (inaudible) had a
board meeting in Scarsdale.
The whole board, the professors
it was really fun.
God, how many
people do you have here?
- You should see what's
going on on the other side.
We have 750 over all.
- Oh gosh.
- [Gary] Hey guys, hey Nat.
And so, yeah, it's pretty good.
It's like,
I'm very big on HR, EQ,
all that stuff.
("Don't Mind" by Rey-Topol)
If you go on YouTube right now,
there's videos of me
10 years ago tasting wine.
- [David] Really?
- And it became huge to the
point where the Washington Post
said I was the most
influential wine critic besides
Robert Parker in the world.
- [David] Wow.
- I became, it was really cool.
I was the real wine guy.
There's a crazy professor there
that would use my videos that
I told you about earlier,
the biggest wine class in
America is at Virginia Tech.
For people that
are seniors, right?
Or 21?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- [Gary] You got to be 21.
And so he started using my
content 'cause I was the most
relatable thing
to anybody under 30.
- [David] So were you
knowledgeable about wine when
you were a teenager?
- Yes.
When I was 15 years old,
I memorized every
Robert Parker
score of every wine ever.
Okay, yeah, let's do that.
Andy, do me a favor, have Tyler
introduce you guys on email.
Just so it's there.
- [Russell] 'Sup?
- [Gary] Hey Rus.
How are you?
- [Russell] How you doin', man?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
Looking forward to our meeting.
- How are you, sir?
- [David] I know you.
We've met about
four or five times.
We speak together
at The New School.
- Yes.
- The Valerie Bar
where there, with...
- How many years ago was that?
- I'm Michael, Michael's agent.
- Right, but how long?
- Many years.
Valerie Bar was many years ago.
- Yeah, of course. Yeah.
- [David] We spoke
together. I'm a big fan.
- [Russell] He know
hip hop. (Gary laughs)
- [David] Sit down.
- [Gary] How you doing?
We're just catching up.
Yep.
- [David] You're asking advice.
- Right, that's
the world you know.
- [David] I want to
give you the best advice,
I'm a knowledgeable guy.
I'm not trying to
steal (inaudible).
- David, when you did the Nike,
when you guys did the
Adidas thing, you guys.
- Bought.
- Me?
- [Russell] Yeah.
- Yeah, but I watch the
documentaries but I'm 41.
I'm much older--
- I'm 60, 59.
- [David] 59. I'm 66.
- Yeah but that stuff you guys
did was like I lived in Jersey.
I was an 11-year-old kid in
New Jersey when you guys
were doing that stuff.
That was interesting because
that was the first time a
non-athlete thing
did that kind of deal.
Did that hit your guys' radar?
That's where you guys
have an interesting cross over.
- [David] I got to run.
- [Gary] I love you, pal.
Good to see you.
Yeah, of course.
I'll talk to you soon.
- [Russell] Nice
to see you again, man.
- Likewise. I think I
might see you in 10 years.
(laughs)
- [Gary] I'll see you soon.
- [David] Alright.
- [Gary] Alright,
give some thought
to what I said and ping me.
- [David] I will. Love it.
- [Gary] Let's go.
Hey, where are we going?
- [Russell] This way.
- [Gary] Oh, of course, David.
How've you been?
- [Russell] Good.
- [Gary] Thanks, man.
Is this us?
- [Russell] No.
- [Gary] You were here,
not at this office.
We moved here in August.
You were here like a year ago,
right before we moved.
- [Russell] (inaudible) digital.
- [Gary] Yes, that's right.
That's exactly right.
Hey guys, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm the CEO of VaynerMedia.
- [Man] Perfect timing,
by the way.
- [Gary] I was like yeah,
I was watching from afar.
Trying to milk every second.
("Don't Mind" by Rey-Topol)
- [Anthony] How's it going?
Anthony Rondinone.
- Anthony.
- How are you?
- A pleasure, man.
- [Anthony] Wow,
so nice to meet you.
- Thank you, my man.
- Hey, how's it going?
- I'm Tyler. Nice
to finally meet you.
- I'm excited, man.
- Yeah, so I'm an artist.
I'm actually more of a musician
than an artist but I started
painting a long time ago but
I came across your book and
I started reading it.
I actually know Greg Snyder.
- Yes! Of course, I know him.
Anybody who's a
Jets fan, I know.
- (laughs) I figured.
Yeah, he's awesome.
I went to school with him.
I read your book and it spoke
to a lot of things that I was
already thinking so it just kind
of inspired me so I wanted to
kinda paint this
for you as a thank you.
- [Gary] You're a good dude.
Thank you.
Dude.
- [Anthony] This
is kind of my style.
This kinda splatter paint.
- [Gary] This is
incredible, brother.
That is really nice.
You made 17 of them?
- [Anthony] No, no, no, no, no.
- [Gary] Oh, that's
just the date, got it.
I was like why'd I
get number 3 of 17.
And this?
DRock!
- [Anthony] And this DRock.
- Where's DRock?
Is DRock here?
Get you some exposure.
DRock, look what you got?
- [Anthony] I made this for you!
- [DRock] Wow!
That's amazing.
- Shake the man's hand.
- Well done.
- [Anthony] How you doin'?
A friend that I know started
working for Gary a long time ago
before I knew anything
about like Gary or anything.
And then recently, in the past
like probably year and a half,
I actually came across
Gary's book, #AskGaryVee.
Just picked it
up for some reason.
I was like
alright, I'll look at this.
I want to learn more
about entrepreneurship,
all that kind of stuff.
Just what
successful people have to say.
Read the whole thing and it just
resonated with I guess how
I think of things.
So after I read this book, yeah,
it just inspired me to do things
in a slightly different
way with my art that
I started doing
in the past year.
Figured I wanted to
paint Gary and give it to him
sort of as a thank you.
So I just kinda painted a
portrait of him and then posted
it on Twitter.
He responded in
like three minutes.
He was like,
"Yeah, I'll take it."
And I was just like holy shit.
And me and Tyler talked, we set
this thing up and now I got to
meet him because of
that which is just awesome.
You know?
- [Gary] I don't need
Steven Ross'
or Barry Dillar's or Steve Jobs'
point of view because
I only care about what
the market is saying right now.
- [Man 2] And
shifting based off of action.
- [Gary] I don't think I have,
I'm only yes to the market.
I'm not the typical,
I think people are confused.
I don't think
I have any opinions.
I think I'm just reacting.
You know what I mean?
I don't feel like they're mine.
So I have no ego in them.
I don't need a
closed group of like,
yes, you're the man.
- [Man 2] Right, right, right.
- [Gary] Right?
I don't think they're mine.
I think I'm and
interpreter of it.
- [Man 2] What about
non-business things?
Like how do you in personal?
- [Gary] No, yeah.
- [Man 2] I'm just curious.
- [Gary] You know, your friends
and your relationships and you
engage in them and
you know, I don't know.
I'm very big on
serendipity and osmosis.
- [Man] Hmmm.
- I think people overthink
those things a little bit.
Good day, bunch of internal
meetings with senior leadership.
Just client stuff.
Russell Simmons,
David Falk, Michael Jordan,
Patrick Ewing's agent.
Patrick Ewing made it palpable.
Good day.
- [Man 2] Last thing is that you
already started talking about
this but when did you
realize this was real?
You know when
you start a business,
you're sort of like faking
it 'til you make it and you
obviously had a skill
that you were applying.
But when was like holy shit you
looked around and you were like,
this is happening?
What was that moment?
- The thing with me is that if
I'm actually running a business,
it's a foregone conclusion.
So it was really August 2011
when I decided to actually be
the day-in, day-out CEO.
And then immediately
knew we were gonna win.
Like blind faith in
my business ability.
It was the second
I knew I was gonna do it,
I knew it was gonna win.
Like just complete
and utter blind faith.
- [Man 2] Hmmm.
- It's just what I'm good at.
You know?
- [Man 2] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And again, you
have to understand,
this is where people completely
don't understand me at all.
I am not wrapped
up in my own shit.
I look like I am, I get it.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- The reason I win so
much is it's them, not me.
It's why I'm popular.
- [Man 2] Right.
- It's them, not me.
It's you guys, not me.
Now, I know when I have to have
responsibility to make
tough decisions, org changes,
strategy changes.
We're gonna be big
on influencer marketing.
Like I know what
I have, what I do.
- [Man 2] Mhmmm.
- But I don't need
anybody to make me feel good.
That's what people don't get.
I'm the ultimate
not insecure person.
So, I don't need it.
I don't care if people think I'm
the most humble or the most ego.
They both feel the same to me.
They're people's interpretation
of the serendipity of the
interactions they have with me.
- [Man 2] Hmmm.
- I'm empathetic
to how they got there.
I'm equally empathetic to
somebody who thinks I'm the
greatest genius to
somebody thinking I'm the
greatest snake oil salesman.
I get it.
Which then allows
me to just go fast.
- [Man 2] Hmmm.
- Just not thinking about that.
I know I have good intent.
I know who I am.
I'm whole inside.
- [Man 2] So you
just don't overthink?
- I don't.
("The Creation of
Earth" by Vvitch)